today I'm having a date assume date
excitement a monomeric 90-day fiance
star Fernando Flores has moved on with
get this fellow reality star on Monday's
episode of 90-day fiance self
quarantined the 22 year old shared that
she and her ex 33 year-old Jonathan
Rivera had both signed their divorce
papers officially marking the end of
their relationship and Fernanda who
lives in Chicago with her roommate
Vanessa said she has a new love interest
and you might just recognize his face he
was a Google player he's been in a few
reality TV shows before yeah those
reality shows Beca kufran season of The
Bachelorette and season six of bachelor
in paradise
I definitely think what I had with Becca
was special it's tough to think that I
walked away from that yep that's 31
year-old clay Harbor he's so hot
fernanda said that the two connected on
social media and they actually went on a
date before the corona virus pandemic
hit we went in the first state and I
remember I was holding his arms
huge heart
but the timing wasn't right because she
was still getting over her split from
Jonathan wasn't ready to be dating but
now we want to you know date again but
now we're stocking home with the
quarantine and we figure we could have a
ritual days yeah so we got to go on that
virtual dinner date and they got right
down to business
looking forward to this they talked
about wanting kids in the future he
showed off his salsa dancing and at the
end of the date she blew him a kiss
naturally people went off on social
media weighing in on the new match made
in reality TV heaven one fan wrote
that's an odd duo while another said
holy hell what a crossover back in March
Fernanda announced she was officially
single
on Instagram after finalizing her
divorce so I'm officially single
officially deborde's Fernanda and
Jonathan's rocky romance was documented
on 90 day fiancé season six the two met
at a club in Mexico while he was on
vacation he proposed just three months
later and they were married in May 2018
but as viewers might recall Fernanda
found another woman's underwear in her
ex's house and according to her a lot of
what happened after the incident went
down off-camera that same week I found a
lot of stuff that's just under water sex
toys pictures movies
dude you're supposed to left your path
behind and start fresh with me I know
that you're a single man I know that
you're older than me I wasn't
understanding why if we agreed to start
fresh and he knew and I'm about to move
with him and I realized that not
everything it's how it seems the couple
announced that they were parting ways in
2019 and in March she straight-up danced
out of the courthouse after finalizing
her divorce now what kind of corn very
happy very very happy
she explained on Instagram quote this
isn't a failure this is a win excited to
see what God has planned for me